(audience applauds)
- Graduates of the Class of 2023,
family members and friends,
it gives me great pleasure to welcome you
and to offer a few words this morning.
First, there is a wonderful Yale tradition
that I'd like to honor right now.
So may I ask all of the families
and friends who are here today to rise
and to recognize the outstanding
and graduating members
of the Class of 2023?
(audience cheers and applauds)
And now, may I ask the Class of 2023
to consider all those who have supported
your arrival at this milestone
and to please rise and recognize them?
(audience cheers and applauds)
Okay, that concludes the
aerobic exercise portion
of our program.
(audience chuckles)
Today, as we assemble at an
inflection point in your lives
between the shortest,
gladdest years of life
and exciting new chapters
that lie beyond them,
I wanna discuss the importance
of community engagement
here in New Haven and in your future.
So raise your hand if you participated
in a service organization on campus
or in our local community
during your time at Yale.
Hey, that's a lot of hands.
(audience claps)
It's a lot of hands, but I'm not surprised
because I know that nearly all
of you have immersed yourself
in the work of civic betterment
in one form or another
over the past four years.
Despite the rigors of your studies,
you have promoted literacy
with New Haven Reads,
brought the basics of computer science
to public school classrooms
through Code Haven,
and tutored immigrants for whom English
is not a first language
as Bridges ESL volunteers.
You've likewise helped
us to alleviate housing
and food insecurity through the Yale
Hunger and Homelessness Action Project,
supported your student neighbors
as Walden Peer counselors
and engaged in remedial climate action
with the Urban Resources Initiative.
Even on the heels of
final exams last week,
many of you volunteered in
Yale Day of Service activities.
You have collectively pursued
unfinished work in our society
and affirmed what Coretta Scott King
observed on this campus in 1969,
that students want to start
today on the world of tomorrow.
Although not necessarily
learned in the classroom,
this spirit of service is every bit a part
of what makes a Yale
education distinctive.
And in all, we estimate
that you and your classmates
contributed a remarkable
150,000 hours each year,
each year you were here,
to community-based causes.
Rather than reflect on how your work
in this community will reverberate
long after you exit Phelps
Gate, I want to implore you
to replicate it no
matter where you go next.
For several years now, even
before the COVID-19 pandemic,
this country has seen a
decline in social capital
and the value we derive
from positive connections
with other people.
Political scientist, Robert
Putnam, diagnosed this decay
through something that actually
used to be fairly common
in my time as a teenager
in Buffalo, New York,
bowling leagues.
Putnam, and eminent Yale alumnus,
observed that more Americans are bowling
but fewer in organized leagues.
So he used the vivid
metaphor of bowling alone
to represent the breakdown of
traditional social networks
in contemporary society.
As a touchstone of his thesis,
Putnam pointed to a reduction
in membership among
organizations like PTAs,
the Red Cross, Lions Clubs
from its mid-20th century peak.
He found, in short, that we
are dropping out in droves
from organized community life.
In the two decades since
"Bowling Alone's" publication,
US Census data have similarly
depicted a sharp decrease
in community involvement.
The hours donated annually
by volunteers, for example,
halved between the start of the century
and your first year at Yale.
And the national volunteering rate
dropped an additional
seven percentage points
by the time you were a junior.
So what happens when social ties weaken?
Certainly something is
lost in our communities.
But we also retreat into ourselves.
We become isolated, and we feel lonely.
Surveys indicate the alarming
prevalence of these feelings.
60% of Americans, including
a full 75% of younger people
like yourselves now
struggle with loneliness.
Some weeks ago, this frayed social fabric
compelled US Surgeon General Vivek Murthy,
also a Yale alumnus,
to declare a loneliness
epidemic in America.
"The ramifications for
our health and wellbeing
are wide ranging," he says,
"but an antidote is within reach."
As Dr. Murthy remarked
last semester here at Yale,
community service activities
connect us with somebody deeply
on something that matters,
but also reaffirmed to us
that we have value to bring to the world.
They help us to rebuild that
esteem which gets shredded
when we are lonely.
Of course, service activities
are as solitary for society
as they are for ourselves.
Social capital can contribute
to positive outcomes
in education, children's welfare,
the safety of our neighborhoods,
economic prosperity,
and even democracy itself.
Our civic and social lives form the mortar
of American society and a
pillar of public health.
We must, therefore, redouble
our resolve to rescue them.
In doing so, we should be
mindful of a distinction
articulated by philosopher John Dewey,
on whom Yale bestowed an
honorary degree in 1951.
"Many social reformers," he lamented,
"however noble their
intentions have failed to meet
their ambitions because
they were committed
to doing good for rather
than with others."
So for our part, we aspire to make Yale
the most civically-engaged university
by strengthening the ties that bind us
to our host city, New Haven.
Like most of you, I arrived
in New Haven as a visitor.
I remember my first days at Yale
as an entering graduate student in 1981.
I was blown away by the
beauty of the stone buildings
and by the tastiness of the local pizza.
Over the next four decades,
I discovered that New
Haven is a fascinating
and vibrant community in which to live.
The Elm City quickly
became my and Marta's home
and an integral part of our identities.
Your time here may well
be shorter than ours,
although I urge you to
consider adding your talents
to the rich mix of what
makes this a great place
to work and live.
But whether you remain in New
Haven or not after graduation,
we all experience a
distinct bond between Yale
and our host city.
And the depth of that relationship
was reflected most recently
by the historic pledge
to extend our lead as the
institution that makes the largest
annual voluntary financial contribution
of any US college or
university to its home city.
But-
(audience applauds)
But a university's
responsibility to its host city
goes beyond, goes beyond
financial contributions,
what Dewey might have
deemed worthwhile ends.
It should also be intellectual,
it should be innovative,
it should be human, it should
be with as well as for.
The metaphor of the ivory tower
walled off from its surroundings,
and at Yale, protected by moats
and gates is no longer apt.
What is real instead is a social contract
in which we willingly and
readily obligate ourselves
to the welfare of one another.
So our task, even as we
increase our voluntary payments,
is to reinforce our culture of engagement.
Alumni, such as Patricia
Melton, exemplify this ideal.
A native of Cleveland, Ohio,
a 1983 graduate of Yale College,
and with similar to about 20% of you,
the first in her family to attend college,
Patricia has dedicated her
career to helping young people
in our community.
For over a decade, she
has led New Haven Promise,
a Yale-funded scholarship and
career development program
that is one of our most
treasured collaborations.
Patricia's inspired
work delivers the dream
of college for scores of young people
who otherwise wouldn't
be able to afford it.
Importantly, the Promise program
encourages college students
to return to New Haven following
graduation just as she did.
The results have been superb.
By the end of this decade, we
expect to have welcomed back
thousands of promise
alumni who will accelerate
the Renaissance well underway in our city,
alongside many other Yale initiatives
such as the recently established
Pennington Fellowship
and the Center for Inclusive Growth.
And we also look forward
to joining the mayor's
recently announced tutoring program
for New Haven School children.
It is heartening to
consider these extraordinary
community partnerships that
alumni like Patricia unleash,
and as Yale's newest
graduates, you can soon enrich.
Before we say farewell,
I wish to hearken back
to when we first met.
You may recall that four years
ago I penned an open letter
to welcome the Class of 2023.
In it, I asked you to consider
a series of questions,
among them, why are we here?
Why is Yale here?
What is our purpose?
Of course, improving the
world through research
and education is Yale's mission.
The crises that surround us,
pressing in nature and
often planetary in scale,
compel the Class of 2023 to mobilize
its unique gifts for a world in need.
And the liberal education
you've acquired at Yale
has prepared you well to do so.
Look closely though, and you will see
that in a pithy mission
statement dedicated
to articulating our
university's entire purpose,
Yale puts equal emphasis on
where we hope to achieve it.
Indeed, we devote ourselves
to improving the world.
As we do that, we retain our focus
on the interdependent community
in which this work is advanced,
ever attuned to our immediate
social surroundings.
As Justice Sonia Sotomayor said
to Yale Day of Service
participants some years ago,
"Our tradition of civic work
is expressed in many ways
including in city halls, in
state houses, in Congress,
in the cabinet, and yes,
even on the Supreme Court.
But this tradition of
service," she continued,
"is also powerfully expressed daily
by countless Yale
graduates, fired by a spirit
of generosity, by relief
workers amidst disasters,
mentors in urban schools,
volunteers in parks,
libraries and museums,
and so many other roles."
I think, for instance,
of a former student,
Caroline Tanbee Smith,
whose love for this city
was catalyzed by her president's
public service fellowship.
Caroline stayed in New Haven
after graduating from Yale College.
And in 2017, she co-founded a nonprofit
community accelerator dedicated
to making entrepreneurship
more accessible,
particularly for low-income
community members, women
and people of color,
helping them to create
new jobs and generate
millions of dollars in
revenue for this region.
"Those efforts, your efforts,"
Justice Sotomayor said,
"may not make headlines,
but they most surely make a difference."
Indeed, your efforts as
students engaged in service
showcase why the where of Yale's
mission statement matters.
Your efforts show that the
transformative is within reach,
that there is marvelous
grandeur in the constellation
of seemingly small acts of
service with and for each other
that together constitute
a thriving civic life
on this campus.
The sum of your contributions has brought
immense pride to Yale and
an equal measure of progress
to our community.
Here you have heeded Bob
Dylan and strapped yourself
to a tree with roots and nourished them.
Of course, we hope some
of you will consider
his next refrain also,
"You ain't going nowhere,"
and that you join us
right here in New Haven.
But for those of you
who will soon disperse
around the globe, also a fine outcome,
we hope too that you will
reprise what you have done here.
We hope that you'll be known
as much for your curiosity
of mind as your generosity of spirit.
We hope that wherever it is
upon life's sea you sail,
you will arrive there,
not only as proud alumni
of this university, but as
emissaries of its ethos,
ready once again to raise
your hand and engage.
Congratulations, Class of 2023.
(audience applauds)